your loved ones are dying and zombies
are coming for your flesh there's no way
out except through one train to busan
but you'll never get there what do you
do i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the zombies in seoul station no one
knows it yet but by morning over 30
million people will die as the sun sets
on a peaceful soul for the very last
time a homeless man is bleeding out from
a bite mark as he walks into seoul
station the man then plops down near the
stairs in a metro full of people the
deadliest virus in human history is
flowing through his body and he is about
to get everyone killed by nightfall in
another part of town we see hie sun an
unemployed bum or she might as well be
waking up in her boyfriend's tiny messy
apartment and goes looking for him the
rent is due and the landlord is pissed
hie soon finds her boyfriend at internet
cafe and catches him trying to pimp her
out online for cash and she flips out a
fight breaks out and cue the yelling in
tears cause it's oh so sad the boyfriend
then breaks up with her and storms off
and now with no boyfriend and no home
kie soon breaks down crying she decides
to head to seoul station where the
homeless are to seek shelter for the
night not realizing that this horrifying
night isn't over in fact her fun times
are just about to start meanwhile the
boyfriend meets up with a man who
responded to the ad he posted online
turns out this man is here soon's father
and he's royally pissed and forces the
boyfriend to take him to hiesun little
does the boyfriend know that hiesun's
daddy will destroy everything he loves
soon enough back at seoul station he
soon is walking past rows of homeless
people and suddenly a bunch of men run
past her terrified and that's when she
sees it a horrifying zombie pouncing on
the warm flesh of a human terrified at
what she sees hie soon starts running
for her life that's a bona fide zombie
if i've seen one and now we're in
trouble because we're about to be alone
with undead flesh eating monsters who
will never not stop feeding which means
we're screwed but we don't have time to
think because in this situation it's
fight or flight and i'm definitely
choosing flight because i'm cold in a
tight dress and not prepared for
anything there's actual zombies here i
can't do [ __ ] and forget arming yourself
with anything cause down here we're
already at a disadvantage being cornered
and outnumbered we don't need to fight
we need to run i don't need to be the
fastest so long as i'm not the slowest
and if i can run past the older people i
guarantee the zombies will pick them
over me in fact if we wanted to be even
more heartless i'd purposely trip stop
and push anybody i see on the way out of
the metro they may have a head start on
me but i'm younger more agile at least
compared to their malnourished starved
selves if y'all wanted to be extra
sneaky i would have darted right behind
the exit from the metro behind that
little wall there if the zombie's line
of sight was cut off from the corner of
the wall for just a second that would
have been time i could have used to hide
and run in the opposite direction whilst
the suckers lead them the other way
heisun and the others find their way
into a police station where they beg the
cops to listen to them claiming the
people have gone mad the world is about
to end and these cops of course don't
listen until the brain hungry suckers
come crashing through the door but soon
and a group decide to hold up in a cell
as a last resort turns out one of them
is bitten and the cop guy isn't looking
too hot he makes a stand as he threatens
everyone with his pistol knowing what
they know that he's already dead then
tank top dude makes lemonade with the
situation and beats the [ __ ] out of cop
guy causing him to pass out for good at
the same time jaeson grabs the gun in
shock and fear until tank top dude
swipes it from her just then cop guy
comes back from the dead biting this guy
until he gets shot in the big thinker by
tank top dude ugh this was a bad
situation from the start i wouldn't have
even stopped by the police station to
begin with there are way too many
zombies coming for us if we wanted some
police attention i would have at the
most grabbed a piece of rock whilst
running to throw at the police glass
door which would have gotten the
attention of the cops without slowing me
down but since we already cornered
ourselves zombies are already something
that people would have had a hard time
believing but unlike tank top dude
whining to the police i wouldn't have
used the word insane instead i would
have yelled and screamed that there was
a huge fire outside which would have
been much more believable and would have
gone the cops to get off their asses now
no cop in their right mind would let me
hide under their desk especially if they
didn't know what was going on to begin
with and using anything to chain the
door would have been useless since it's
made of glass and doesn't seem to be
bulletproof i would have only gone
through there in order to divert the
zombies by going through the station and
out through one of the few exits that
police stations usually have either
exiting through the employee entrance
the intake entrance or the emergency
exit however i would have only done this
once the zombies entered the police
station to make sure that no cops try to
stop me or worse tase me as the last
thing we want to be is free fried food
for these brain munchers and if we're
talking about brain munchers we as a
society have gone to the point where
zombies are common pop culture knowledge
they didn't need to wait for that bitten
cop to get up and bite hoodie guy in
order to have known that he was going to
turn into a zombie stop being stupid
stupid hye soon lays trapped with tank
top dude as the zombies outnumber their
bullets they will die if they don't do
something but then help suddenly arrives
or at the very least a distraction as
riot control shows up late to the meat
party the zombies attack them as hie
soon and tank top dude bolt out of the
back entrance of the station narrowly
escaping through the small alley until
they run into an ambulance it's chaos
everywhere as ambulance guy quickly
picks them up and drives off he tries to
treat both his soon and tank top dude
but something is up he soon checks her
phone and realizes she's got missed
calls from her ex-boyfriend an ambulance
guy then tells them that the hospital
they're heading to is full of bite
victims so they'll have to wait their
turn but tank top guy waits for nothing
as he freaks out and demands the
ambulance to stop getting physical with
the driver causing them to crash alright
this whole nonsense could have been
avoided if they just layered their
efforts with some calm cool
collectedness i would have used the time
the riot squad gave me as time i could
have used to scavenge what i could
quickly from the police station such as
checking out anything i could have used
for armor and the armory for weapons as
it likely would have only been
accessible with a key card so i would
have checked out cop guy's corpse in the
jail cell first now there were quite a
few zombies but from the looks of things
the ride squad seemed to outnumber them
which means we probably would have been
safe if we waited it out anyway and that
means we had time to search for weapons
before leaving out of the back i would
have placed useless hye soon on lookout
in a hidden corner as to not be visible
and even more useless and would have
gone myself to search for the armory if
i couldn't find it within a short period
of time or if it was empty then i would
have at least grabbed myself a stapler
or a sharp pen on the way out something
at least the ambulance was a great move
as you don't want to be caught dead on
foot anyways and it has the stuff we
need for great first aid if you need it
however forcing it to crash was not
needed i would have calmly stated that
we wanted to leave the ambulance and not
to be driven to the hospital or i would
have grabbed a sharp scalpel or some
sharpened equipment such as a sterile
needle and would have threatened the
ambulance driver to pull over the crash
itself we couldn't have done much if we
were the ones to set it off however
assuming we survived at which we did
then i would have first and foremost
picked up a first aid kit from within
the truck or would have made my own
homemade first aid bag making sure to
collect various items very likely to be
found within an ambulance like aloe vera
gel scissors medical tape
anti-inflammatory drugs basically enough
items to ensure that we can treat most
simple wounds make a sling make a splint
treat a burn among other things as bites
won't be the only thing we need to look
out for now that no one's coming to save
us and it's only a matter of time until
our luck runs out after the crash hiesun
and tank top dude walk out without a
scratch and then make their way towards
the metro and with a little muscle and
some freak motivation they managed to
bust their way through the closed metro
entrance they don't realize it yet but
if they don't find somewhere to hold up
it's only a matter of time until
millions of zombies come for their
throats they keep walking with no phone
signal or idea of where they're going as
all the stations are filled with zombies
until they reach heihyoun station hiei
soon finally gets reception and calls
her boyfriend to tell him her location
just as they run into another group of
terrifying zombies they run for their
lives with more and more zombies joining
the chase not knowing where or how
they'll make it out of this one until
luck plays to their favor they spot a
group of men standing around a makeshift
barricaded wall carrying weapons and
balls of steel they signal over to his
soon and tanked up dude to come over to
them quickly it's safe to assume by how
they walked out of that metro that there
were no zombies in there and so i would
have stayed hidden on the steps just
below the street's line of sight before
making that call this could have helped
them avoid those first two zombies to
begin with while we waited nice and
comfortably for our rescue to come to us
if we had to expose ourselves for the
sake of catching a phone signal she
could have at least stayed low and
hidden behind a trash can or something
and not stand in the middle of the
street like an idiot also i'd start to
worry about my feet as you my dear still
have no shoes on even before an
apocalypse i could have told you that
walking barefoot in the city could
result in all sorts of nasty things
sneaking into your foot like ringworms
this was our chance to at least find
some shoes potentially better protective
clothing and weaponry lying around
because as much as i hate her and love
tank top dude they are really stupid to
not have bothered to look for any
weapons or better clothing by now this
would have been one of my top priorities
from the get-go especially when we have
extra moments of peace and quiet also
we've gone a long while without any food
and water the infection has taken over
the town and there are bound to be cars
parked around if we look for a family
car we may be able to salvage some food
and water and stay hidden inside and
wait for our ex-boyfriend if we're lucky
enough to find the keys we could drive
it circling around the block until our
ex-boyfriend reaches us and at least
this way we won't get mouth-tagged by
zombies hell we could have driven away
without a boyfriend at this point girl
power now as much as i'd like to break
into shops to scavenge unless we could
pick the lock breaking in would have
been too noisy it is night time after
all and with the power grid still up we
definitely would have risked setting off
any potential store alarms and then we'd
definitely be in trouble aside from
raiding any cars i would have also taken
this opportunity to look for any alleys
full of dumpsters where we could have
looked for cardboard and layered
materials to wrap up our arms and legs
and to protect us from bites and if we
salvaged any tape from the ambulance
which i talked about earlier then we
would have at the very least would have
been able to create some makeshift
zombie armor hiesoon and tank top dude
make it over to the makeshift barricade
as mr tough guy here and his friends
fight off the rest of the zombies
chasing them inside the barricade lots
of people sit and stand terrified as the
entire alley is blocked off one side
from the barricade and the other side by
the police who are threatening them to
leave as they claim that the scared folk
are participating in an unlawful
assembly everybody is trapped and
everyone knows it there on borrowed time
hundreds then thousands and then
millions of zombies close in quickly
overwhelming mr tough guy and his
friends as they struggle to fight them
all off people are dying left and right
as tank tab dude tries to climb the bus
but is fatally shot killing him the
soldiers aren't playing around and are
ready to kill anyone who tries to climb
over that bus forcing everybody inside
to exit from the other way where
millions upon millions of zombies are
coming from this barricade is about to
collapse as countless zombies close in
they break through the barricade defense
as mr tough guy and his friends fail to
handle them resulting in an
all-you-can-eat korean barbecue as the
zombies pounce chew and bite their way
through everybody the smell of walking
corpses and people dying horrible bloody
deaths is enough to scare the [ __ ] out
of mr tough guy as he gives up and takes
off making a makeshift ladder and begins
climbing over the electric line jae soon
tries to do the same but struggles to
hang on as mr tough guy comes back to
give her a hand and of course kills
himself in the process she manages to
climb to safety for a brief second
before she gets chased down by more
zombies through an office up the stairs
and onto the roof doing crazy stunts
until one of them trips her along a
metal scaffolding causing her to fall
hard you know what i have to commend his
own for not getting herself killed
sooner it's honestly quite impressive
and unbelievable well done she could
have saved herself and mr tough guy if
she had chosen to climb in a more
efficient manner using the monkey hung
technique which is a climbing technique
similar to how monkeys climb as this
would have been a lot faster and more
efficient sparing the weight of the
entire body by using the rope to support
the legs as well this would have
prevented her feet from hanging swinging
like tarzan on the monkey bars with
their feet hanging was just a recipe for
disaster and explained why only mr tough
guy had the proper strength to climb
this way it's way harder she made the
right move on not waiting around because
even though she was at a safe vantage
point from before waiting there would
have only increased the risk of
potentially getting shot or injured from
the already trigger happy police force
as they clearly have no idea what's
really going on or who the enemy really
is after landing on the ledge from the
climb i would have looked around the
building first looking through each of
the accessible windows before making my
move and i would have taken off my
clothing to wrap around my arm and elbow
before smashing in the window now we may
have taken off our only bit of clothing
but this layer around our arms could
have also served as a layer of hand
protection and would have allowed us to
grab a shard of the broken window glass
safely before combating the zombie that
was in the office giving us an edge over
the zombie with our very own makeshift
weapon he soon was already in a sealed
room and last time i checked zombies
can't open doors at least not easily
this means in theory i could have
cleared the hallway room by room using
the opening and closing of doors as
methods of allowing me to safely control
the entries and exits of this area
without getting bitten by surprise
approaching this situation more slowly
and carefully could have also let us
sneak up on that group of zombies that
he soon passed and if we wanted to we
could have also closed that door
trapping the zombies in the room jason's
noisy and panicked approach to this
situation caused a herd of zombies to
chase her and if we failed to close the
door to the zombies earlier we still
have another method of taking them out
after jumping down from the roof he soon
could have stayed put for a sec before
crossing the scaffolding by letting the
stupid zombies throw themselves from the
roofs like dodos off a cliff also why is
she crossing on the edge of the metal
frame it would have been safer to cross
from within the middle in case you fell
you'd at least have a shot to grab on to
something hie soon wakes up after the
fall and realizes she's on the balcony
of another apartment but is it safe
injured tired and afraid yay soon calls
out for help but unluckily no one in the
apartment answers turns out jae-soon is
in a model apartment building filled
with showroom furniture she checks the
place out and realizes it's all model
apartments around her with nobody dead
or alive to be seen sad and all alone
she gives up as she gets a call from her
ex-boyfriend asking where she is she
tells him her location and then sits and
waits exhausted from all the death
around her hie soon takes a nap as she
comes to the realization that everyone
she has ever loved or will love is dead
and it's only a matter of time until
it's her turn jason wakes up to her
ex-boyfriend and everything is all happy
boyfriend girlfriend make up session
until another older man enters the
apartment jaeson looks shocked and
terrified as the boyfriend says he met
jason's dad at her apartment earlier
that night he soon reveals that this man
is not her dad but actually her daddy as
in her ex pimp turns out jason owes mr
pimp some money pissed off at hie soon
mr pimp tries to take her from the
ex-boyfriend as they both get into a
fight but this fight turns violent
involving a lot of quick moves as mr
pimp slices the ex-boyfriend's throat
the ex-boyfriend slowly dies as hie soon
bolts out of there turning out to be
just as cold as the corpses she's
running from mr pimp goes searching for
jae soon looking in all the model
apartments until hie soon comes from
behind and tries to knock him out with a
marble statue but mr pimp is too damn
quick for poor old ice queen he soon as
he blocks her and beats her to the
ground causing hie soon to pass out holy
crap this girl can't catch a break first
thing i would have done is checked for
injuries and bruises because apparently
we're korean superwoman next i would
have checked security for the building
even venturing down those stairs to see
if everything was properly locked down
and that there were no zombies down
there for defense we could have brought
along the knife from the fake kitchen
and by falling into this apartment model
we've already secured a possible rest
location it being nighttime means that
this place would have already been
closed and locked down for hours and has
more than enough beds for me and my ego
i also would have looked for a vending
machine or a fridge containing water as
this being a model apartment it's not
crazy to think that they would have had
stocks of water for guests already
available nearby these are the first few
things i would have done before calling
our ex bae in regards to our
ex-boyfriend and our pimp daddy husson
acted useless till the end there were
several items in that apartment that
hieson could have used to try and take
mr pimp out before and after he already
had that knife from the chair to the pot
to the glasses and plates pretty much
anything in that kitchen could have been
used but while driving the chair into mr
pimp would have made for a good tactical
barrier between his knife and our flesh
jaeson could have grabbed the knife when
mr pimp was busy killing our
ex-boyfriend there were bunches of
knives available to her and she could
have easily sliced his neck or cut right
through his accessible armpit hitting
the shallow axillary artery located
right beneath the surface of the armpit
and one artery that could have done some
serious damage if cut however running
away from mr pimp was also a solid move
although she simply could have hid
behind an entranceway door on the side
away from the door hinge allowing her to
have full access to mr pimp as he would
have entered grabbing his knife with one
hand and stabbing him with the other
seriously injuring him before running
away again this would have been a much
safer option and would have saved us
from directly taking him on an
unconscious jae soon is taken by mr pimp
as he readies to take her on the bed
however he slowly notices that his son
isn't breathing mr pimp is scared and
afraid trying to bring hieson back to
life as he begs for her forgiveness
although in the middle of all of this he
notices a scratch on hieson's right
ankle and a scary infection taking over
her body holy crap as he looks right up
he sees his very own zombie nightmare
right up close like a scared child in
front of a deadly snake mr pimp tries to
back away just as hieson pounces on him
eagerly devouring her new man meal we
look up to see a destroyed city with the
zombie infection now slowly but surely
taking over the entire nation as we look
onto a destroyed soul just as the sun
rises for the next day right on time for
the final departing train to busan and
if you don't want mr pim coming back to
bite your girlfriend then like comment
let us know what you liked and of course
didn't like and check out how to be
playlist down below